Richard Stewart was a British cricket
star in the 1960s playing for Middlesex
good enough to be a homegrown player and
yet this Windrush child can't get a
British passport he was a second-class
citizen really that's all I'm down as
you know but you get used to it
reading back you know get used to it so
we accept it anyway though it's not
right it's nothing we can do about it
now 73 he's deemed an illegal it's a
bitter rejection from a place he's
called home since he was 10 years old
and disappointed because the fact is
when I was playing cricket
I was classified as their own ground
grown player not over seat bias so I
come all of a sudden the C player Prime
Minister's Questions missus my apologize
again to the winds children I want to
say sorry to anyone who has been caused
confusion or anxiety there was no
getting away from Labour's attempt to
lay the blame at her door for the
destruction of Windrush documentation
but she was ready with his zinger of her
own trying to shift the blame onto
labour did the Prime Minister the then
Home Secretary sign off that decision no
the decision to destroy the landing
cards was taken in 2009 under a Labour
government but whenever the decision was
taken the documentation belonging to the
scores of names on these lists from the
National Archives were destroyed by a
department under her watch the
accusation now is that she lost sight of
British people in her pursuit of meat in
immigration targets after days of trying
to clean up the mess today the blame
game began over who's responsible for
the destruction of landing cards but be
under no doubt the buck here stops with
Theresa May focus now shifting towards
the tightening of immigration laws when
she was Home Secretary she had a policy
of creating a hostile environment
for illegal immigrants but the problem
was she caught up a number of innocent
citizens in that net David Lamm his
parents Windrush children he now sits in
the same Parliament as mrs. may all
political parties people recognize that
this has been a whole episode of shame
and actually the policy that sits behind
it creating a hostile environment having
a go immigrants is something that now
needs proper comprehensive review it
sometimes feel a bit lonely in the
comments when you feel like you're the
person that has to stand up and make
these arguments because there's so many
people in there
that just don't have any agency with
these sorts of issues
look when I stood up I'm really
summoning up my parents who aren't with
us anymore but I know that they would
expect me to speak up and I know how
proud they were of this country and how
sad they would be of this moment we've
not got to the place that we need to as
a nation here in Bristol those who were
part of the wind' Ross generation have
lived this history and painted it on
their city walls a hundred and thirteen
cases are now being investigated by the
Home Office while mr. Lamie has called
for a parliamentary debate next week
dozens of lives disrupted plenty more
fallout and plenty more stories to tell
beth rigby sky news